you address this in the book you talk
about erectile dysfunction I have read
and I want to know if this is true that
a man must ejaculate 26 times a month
in order to keep away prostate cancer is
there any truth to this no truth to that
at all there's real data yes I am
completely paranoid and I've been
masturbating like a maniac and you know
I can't hit that number I mean as viral
as I am I can't hit 26 times six times I
mean I'm rubbed raw here I'm Sorry by
you saying you know I can't hit that
number as if I know your masturbatory uh
I've talked to you about this I'm so
glad you said there's no truth to that
because I mean I don't want to make you
uncomfortable but I'm masturbating right
now I'm so on a schedule with this day
listen you've written an important book
again the book of animal Secrets
Nature's lessons for a long and happy
life it took six years to write this and
I'm very proud of it I think they're
they're amazing lessons get a little of
this have you ever had a dog I know
you've got a lot of cats but have you
ever had a dog many dogs dogs sleep all
day the reason is dogs don't get rem or
deep sleep and either do most animals in
nature if they did right in their world
they would be eaten or attacked your
first night in a hotel or in a new
surrounding you sleep like a dog you
don't get deep sleep so there's a simple
way to hack it so I use my iPhone as my
clock for a couple days before I travel
so I have a visual cue I bring a
pillowcase or a pillow with me so I have
a smell and a sense and a feel and I get
more deep sleep my first night in a
hotel I don't sleep like a dog it's an
amazing observation about how dogs sleep
and what we can learn from